Traducteur: Célia SIMON
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il y a quelques années,
j'habitais une maison écologique en paille
dans un hameau écologique en Bretagne.
J'étais alors l'heureux fondateur
et rédacteur en chef
d'un magazine spécialisé
sur la construction écologique.
Ceci explique cela.
Il y avait souvent des visiteurs
qui venaient voir
ces drôles de maisons
et leurs drôles d'habitants.
Un jour, j'ai reçu un groupe de marcheurs
pour leur faire une visite du lieu.
L'un d'eux, âgé d'une vingtaine d'années,
n'arrêtait pas de remettre en question
la taille des maisons qui l'entouraient.
« D'accord, elles sont écologiques,
et très belles
mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont grandes ! »
Agacé, je lui répondais que la mienne
ne faisait que 120 m²,
que lorsque toute la famille recomposée
était là, nous étions quand même cinq,
qu'il y avait en plus un espace bureau
et un chat.
Mais il n'en démordait pas :
« Quand même, c'est vachement grand ! »
Ça m'avait turlupiné
et pendant plusieurs semaines après,
j'ai essayé de me convaincre du contraire.
Mais trop tard !
La graine était semée.
Deux années plus tard, au printemps 2008,
c'est-à-dire il y a presque 10 ans,
donc presque 60 ans pour mon chat,
j'ai décidé d'écrire un article
sur le petit habitat.
Au cours de mes recherches,
je suis tombé sur un type incroyable :
Jay Shafer, un Américain
qui avait construit sa maison de 9 m²
sur une remorque.
Bon, je suis rentré en contact avec lui
pour avoir des photos
et là, ce fut le coup de foudre
avec cette « tiny house » -
cette « minuscule maison » en français.
A vrai dire, si je remonte
quelques années auparavant,
lorsque j'avais 23 ans,
j'étais déjà totalement fan
d'un philosophe américain
qui s'appelle Henry David Thoreau.
Il avait construit sa maison de 14 m²
sur les bords de l'étang de Walden
à Concord, non loin de Boston.
Jay Shafer disait s'inspirer de Thoreau,
j'étais donc naturellement conquis.
J'ai lu tous les écrits de Jay Shafer
qui, comme sa maison, ont l'avantage
d'être tout petits.
(Rires)
Puis, j'ai téléchargé toutes les images
de « tiny houses »
que je pouvais trouver.
Ça y est ! La graine venait de germer.
Pour autant,
il m'aura fallu attendre encore
quelques années
avant de passer du rêve à la réalité.
Nous sommes au début 2013,
alors que j'ai longuement médité
sur mon parcours de vie
en regardant la mer à côté de laquelle
j'habitais désormais, en Normandie.
Je me suis dit que mon heure était venue.
Pas de finir entre quatre planches,
hein, je vous rassure,
mais pour commencer une nouvelle vie
dans une adorable maison en bois.
J'ai alors passé en revue
toutes les joyeuses lois françaises
pour savoir comment construire,
puis déplacer,
et enfin stationner
ces minuscules maisons.
J'ai dessiné mes premiers plans
en n'ayant que quelques photos
de tiny houses américaines sous la main.
Puis, j'ai remarqué que les Américains
ne construisaient des tiny
qu'avec de toutes petites cuisines
car ils ne cuisinent pas beaucoup.
Il fallait donc relever ce défi
typiquement français
de construire des tiny
gastronomiquement compatibles.
(Rires)
Après tout cela, je suis allé voir
un ami charpentier,
afin qu'il m'aide à concevoir
la structure
de la première tiny house française.
Les deux mois de chantier
furent un vrai bonheur.
Un couple d'amis, arboriculteurs bio,
m'avaient accueilli dans leur verger.
J'étais au milieu de centaines
de pommiers en fleurs,
à quelques mètres d'un marais
survolé par les cigognes
et à quelques kilomètres de la mer.
Un coin de paradis.
Le jour, des amis venaient
me rendre visite
ou me donner des coups de main.
Et le soir, je commençais
à trier mes affaires
pour les faire rentrer
dans mon futur espace de vie
de 10 m², avec une mezzanine de 4 m².
Eh oui,
ma maison est à peine plus grande
que votre chambre.
Ou que votre salle de bains,
voire que votre dressing.
Ma maison est minuscule et pourtant,
c'est une vraie maison.
Alors, avant d'aller plus loin,
je vais vous mimer
un aperçu de son volume.
Imaginez que je rentre chez moi ce soir.
Aaah !
Tiny home, sweet tiny home !
Quel bonheur de rentrer chez soi
après avoir passé une si belle après-midi
au théâtre de Clermont-Ferrand.
Ah, mon canapé rouge,
sur lequel j'ai l'habitude de poser
mon petit sac à dos.
Oh ! Mais il fait un petit peu frisquet,
il va falloir que je pense à rallumer
mon poêle à bois de poche.
Mais au fait,
qu'est-ce que je vais cuisiner
dans ma cuisine
gastronomiquement compatible, ce soir ?
Je ne sais pas.
Tiens ! J'ai oublié de fermer la porte
de la salle de bain et des WC
ce matin en partant.
Je devais être un brin stressé,
allez savoir pourquoi.
Il faudra que je relève mes mails
mais peut-être qu'avant,
je vais grimper sur ma mezzanine
- elle est là -
à l'aide de mon escalier,
qui est ici,
pour aller me reposer 5 minutes.
Voilà, maintenant vous voyez mieux
à quoi cela peut ressembler à l'intérieur.
Et extérieurement,
une tiny a la particularité d'être
construite sur une grande remorque,
ce qui lui permet d'être tractée
par un fourgon ou une bonne voiture.
Ma maison peut donc bouger.
Et même aller jusqu'à 80 km/h
sur autoroute.
Alors, tout à l'heure, je vous disais
que la tiny est une vraie maison.
C'est une vraie maison car
elle a tout d'une grande.
Une terrasse, une porte d'entrée couverte,
une cuisine entièrement équipée,
un coin salon,
un espace bureau, une salle de bains,
des toilettes,
une mezzanine pour le couchage.
Elle est bien isolée.
Elle est conçue comme ses grandes sœurs
allemandes ou suédoises
en ossature bois avec
une excellente étanchéité à l'air,
ce qui fait qu'elle ne consomme
presque trois fois rien.
Sa petite taille minimise également
les gaines électriques et les tuyauteries.
Elle est donc intrinsèquement
très économe en énergie.
Alors je vais me permettre maintenant
de répondre aux trois questions que l'on
me pose assez souvent sur les tiny,
et que vous vous posez peut-être
vous-même à cet instant précis.
La première question :
« Mais quelle est la différence
avec un camping-car ? »
(Rires)
La principale différence,
c'est que la tiny est conçue
pour un usage permanent -
c'est une maison -
et non pour un usage saisonnier.
Les autres différences sont :
la qualité des matériaux utilisés,
la conception, le prix -
50% moins élevé -
et l'esthétique.
Et puis il n'existe presque pas
deux tiny semblables.
On est ici plutôt dans du sur-mesure.
Une tiny correspond à son
ou ses habitants.
Ce qui m'amène à la seconde question :
« Mais à combien peut-on vivre
dans cette minuscule mignonne maison ? »
Alors il y en a qui décident
d'y vivre seuls.
Et là c'est le grand confort,
à la limite du luxe.
(Rires)
Et puis il y a ceux
qui tentent l'aventure à deux,
ce qui est parfait pour expérimenter
le véritable amour.
(Rires)
Enfin il y en a d'autres,
notamment mes amis belges,
qui tentent l'aventure à
deux avec leur enfant.
Ils peuvent ainsi goûter aux joies
de l'éducation bienveillante
dans l'infiniment petit.
Et d'après ce qu'ils me racontent,
ce n'est que du bonheur.
Vient enfin la troisième
et dernière question,
qui est :
« Mais, si je devais vivre en tiny,
- pas moi, mais vous -
qu'est-ce que j'emporterais
avec moi comme affaires ? »
C'est le fameux passage obligé
à tous les candidats à une vie en tiny :
trier ses affaires
et ne conserver que l'es-sen-tiel.
Merci.
A l'époque, j'avais pris
une bibliothèque comme celle-ci
afin d'étalonner le volume de mes affaires
qui rentreraient dans ma future maison.
Je vous rassure néanmoins,
ustensiles de cuisine et vaisselle
n'étaient pas compris,
gastronomie française oblige,
vous l'aurez compris.
(Rires)
Donc tous les jours,
je rajoutais quelque chose
dans cette bibliothèque.
Des vêtements, des livres,
des bibelots,
et quand elle était remplie,
et qu'il y avait des biens
que je voulais conserver
alors je devais faire un choix.
Et ce choix, c'est celui de l'es-sen-tiel.
Il est parfois difficile
mais il est indispensable.
Et une fois dans ma tiny,
je me suis rendu compte que
si j'avais envie de m'acheter un livre,
ou que quelqu'un m'offrait quelque chose
que je voulais garder,
alors, je devais enlever quelque chose
de ma tiny.
C'est le principe des vases communicants,
un objet entre, un autre sort.
Alors finalement,
ma tiny m'a invité à vivre mieux
avec moins.
Et la logique d'accumulation matérielle
qui est celle de notre société
n'a plus de prise.
Une visite dans un magasin d'ameublement
ou de décoration
me laisse totalement de marbre.
(Rires)
Si, un jour, vous êtes invité
par un ami qui vit en tiny,
ne lui apportez surtout pas
quelque chose de matériel,
ça pourrait créer chez lui
un cas de conscience terrible.
Surtout s'il s'agit
de la collection complète de la Pléiade
ou des 3 350 épisodes de « Plus Belle
la Vie » en coffret collector.
(Rires)
Non !
Apportez-lui plutôt un bon petit
plat maison fait avec amour.
Tout en dégustant ce plat,
vous apprécierez alors
comment le moindre espace
est optimisé,
ce qui fait gagner du temps
sur le quotidien.
« Tiens, j'ai oublié une fourchette. »
Il suffit de tendre le bras.
(Rires)
« Tu peux me passer le sel,
s'il te plait ? »
Un quart de tour et le voilà.
Et après le repas
vient l'heure du mini-rangement,
éventuellement du mini-ménage.
Car tout est mini
dans une minuscule maison.
Certes,
faire son lit accroupi sur la mezzanine
n'est pas chose aisée
et requiert un brin de souplesse.
Personnellement, ça me donne
une très bonne raison
pour ne pas faire mon lit.
(Rires)
Imaginez alors que cette maison
finit par vous faire gagner du temps,
cette denrée rare et précieuse dans
notre monde qui va à 100 à l'heure.
Un temps que l'on pourra
mettre à profit
pour se reconnecter avec soi-même,
avec les autres,
ou avec la nature.
Et d'ailleurs,
si vous choisissez de mettre votre tiny
dans un coin de campagne,
vous serez sans cesse invité
à aller mettre votre nez dehors.
Parce qu'en plus, techniquement,
il est très compliqué
de faire les cent pas dedans.
(Rires)
Pour autant, on ne se sent pas
à l'étroit dans une tiny,
car elle possède
un grand nombre de fenêtres,
ce qui fait que le regard
peut s'en aller au loin
sans jamais être stoppé par un mur.
Qui plus est,
aller se coucher avec Déneb, Altaïr
et Véga dans la fenêtre de toit,
ou être baigné
par la lumière de la Lune
est une expérience cosmique
absolument grandiose.
Grâce à son grand nombre de fenêtres,
la tiny se transforme également
en excellent observatoire
pour les oiseaux ou les animaux.
Et en parlant d'animaux, justement,
je dois vous avouer que j'ai parfois
un côté un peu ours.
Et alors, ma tiny house se transforme
en tanière à ours.
Lorsque l'on approche,
je grommelle ou je grogne.
Mais ça ne dure pas vraiment longtemps,
car vivre en tiny, c'est également vivre
dans un esprit de partage
et de communication.
D'abord parce qu'il faut
une route suffisamment dégagée
pour faire circuler une maison
de 4 mètres 30 de haut
et 2 mètres 55 de large.
Ensuite parce qu'il sera plus facile
de tirer un tuyau d'eau
et une rallonge électrique
de chez un sympathique voisin tout proche.
Si vivre en tiny, c'est sortir
des sentiers battus,
vivre en tiny, c'est aussi créer du lien
avec les personnes qui accueillent
votre maison nomade sur leur terrain.
C'est le cas de Bernard,
un bricoleur de génie,
homme à tout faire qui pose
sa tiny trois ou six mois
chez des gens en échange
de menus travaux.
Il découvre ainsi de nouveaux paysages
assez régulièrement
et se fait de nouveaux voisins heureux
à chaque fois,
et ça, sans jamais déménager.
Ne pourrait-on pas imaginer ensemble
que dans un futur très proche,
les tiny puissent également
venir remplacer les logements sociaux
ou servir d'hébergements d'urgence ?
Et ce, y compris dans des zones
non constructibles.
On pourrait également imaginer
que des tiny se regroupent ensemble
afin de constituer de petits hameaux,
éphémères ou pas,
et toujours respectueux
de l'environnement.
Souhaitons alors que demain,
la tiny ait sa place
comme nouveau type d'habitat
et nouvelle façon d'habiter,
car cette minuscule maison, croyez-moi,
a un potentiel gi-gan-tesque.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)